Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. Just before two o'clock on the afternoon of the 30th of January 1649, Charles Stuart, King of England, Scotland and Ireland, walked out onto a platform erected outside the banqueting house in Whitehall in London. He read a short speech to his attendants, he knelt and placed his head on the block,
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》。1649年1月30日下午两点前不久，英格兰、苏格兰和爱尔兰国王查理·斯图尔特（Charles Stuart）走上了位于伦敦白厅宴会厅外搭建的平台。他向随从宣读了一份简短的演说，随后跪下，将头放在断头台的木枕上，
and a moment later, the axe came down and he was dead. It was one of the most extraordinary moments in British and indeed in European history, the public trial and execution of an anointed monarch for crimes against the rights and liberties of the people, and almost 400 years on, it still arouses remarkably strong feelings. So Tom, Tom Holland, are you a devotee of Charles King and Martyr? Or do you think the man of blood got what he deserved? Well, I'm very much with Thomas Fairfax, Lord Fairfax,
紧接着，斧头落下，他死了。这是英国乃至欧洲历史上最非同寻常的时刻之一：一位受膏君主因犯下侵犯人民权利与自由的罪行，而公开受审并被处决。将近400年后的今天，它依然激发出异常强烈的情感。那么，汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），你是国王兼殉道者查理的狂热崇拜者吗？还是认为这个血腥之徒罪有应得？嗯，我和托马斯·费尔法克斯（Thomas Fairfax）勋爵立场非常一致，
who commanded the army in the time a massive fence sitter. You're a liberal Democrat on this. Well, basically, so basically, I think that I think Charles was a terrible king. He was obdurate. He refused to negotiate. He pushed England into a second bout of civil war. I think he had blood on his hands at the same time I I don't think that beheading him solved anything uh and I think it was actually in the long run a
他在那个时期统帅军队，是个坚定的骑墙派。在这点上你是个自由民主党人。嗯，基本上是这样，所以我基本上认为查理是个糟糕的国王。他顽固不化。他拒绝谈判。他把英格兰推入了第二次内战。我认为他双手沾满鲜血，但与此同时，我认为斩首他并没有解决任何问题，而且从长远来看，这其实是
victory for for Charles for the monarchy and particularly for Charles's vision of the monarchy um so I think it's an absolute mess um and I don't think it's a kind of you know was he a goody or baddy you know whose side would he be on kind of situation it's just you just you know and speaking as someone who's living in a country that's gone through quite a lot of imponderable political messes recently um you know you just look back at that and think well i'm glad i wasn't alive then and i didn't have to didn't have an opinion very evasive answer but it doesn't really matter what you think because we've got a genuine expert so hold on dominic before before we introduce the genuine expert yeah well let's go to you yeah what do you think um will you i mean people who listen to our recent podcasts will
查理的胜利、君主制的胜利，尤其是查理关于君主制愿景的胜利。所以我觉得这是一团绝对的乱麻。我不认为这是一个“他是好人还是坏人”、“你会站在哪一边”的简单情况。这只是……作为一个生活在一个近期经历过相当多难以捉摸的政治混乱国家的居民，你回首往事就会想，嗯，我很庆幸自己当时不在人世，也不必发表什么意见。这是一个非常规避问题的回答，不过你的想法其实并不重要，因为我们请到了真正的专家。所以，等一下，多米尼克，在我们隆重介绍真正的专家之前，嗯，让我们听听你的高见。你觉得……我是说，听过我们最近播客的听众会
know that i took a very stern and robust line on the princess and the tower thinking that richard the third did it but he was right to do it so So on this, I would say I feel sorry for Charles I. I think his trial and execution was his finest hour, but I think they were probably right to get rid of him. Okay. You know I'm a big Cromwellian, Tom. I do. Yes, I do. I do. So you're more Cromwell than Fairfax on this?
知道，我对塔中的公主采取了非常严厉和坚定的立场，认为理查三世干了这事，但他这么做是对的。所以对于这件事，我想说我为查理一世感到难过。我认为他的审判和处决是他辉煌的时刻，但我认为他们摆脱他可能也是对的。好吧。你知道我是个坚定的克伦威尔主义者，汤姆。我当然知道。是的，我当然知道。所以在这件事上，你比费尔法克斯更倾向于克伦威尔？
Sort of. I'm cruel necessity. I'm wiping away a manly tear, but at the same time, I'm saying he's got to go. Yeah, so that's the story, isn't it? That Cromwell gazed at the corpse of Charles I. Which I'm sure our guest will tell us is totally invented. So let's, so our guest, the great Ted Vallance, who came on last year to talk about Magna Carta,
算是吧。我是残酷的必要性的信奉者。我一边擦着男子汉的眼泪，一边说他必须得走。所以，这就是那个故事，对吧？克伦威尔凝视着查理一世的尸体。我相信我们的嘉宾会告诉我们这完全是虚构的。那么，我们的嘉宾，伟大的泰德·瓦伦斯（Ted Vallance），他去年曾来做客谈论《大宪章》，
and now he's back. And Ted, this, I mean, this is very, very much your field at the moment, isn't it? Because you're actually writing a book about it. who came on last year to talk about Magna Carta and now he's back. And, Ted, this is very, very much your field at the moment, isn't it? Because you're actually writing a book about it, about the trial. Yeah, so I'm working on the trial at the moment, yeah. So there's only really one question, isn't there? It's after Magna Carta's podcast. Ted, do you know Charles I's date? I know the end date very much, Dominic, because you just said it.
现在他又回来了。泰德，这意味着，这现在非常非常符合你的研究领域，对吧？因为你实际上正在写一本关于它的书。去年他来做客谈论《大宪章》，现在他又回来了。泰德，这意味着，这现在非常非常符合你的研究领域，对吧？因为你实际上正在写一本关于它的书，关于这场审判。是的，我现在正在写关于这场审判的书，是的。所以其实只有一个问题，对吧？这是继《大宪章》播客之后的又一个问题。泰德，你知道查理一世的生卒年吗？多米尼克，我非常清楚他的卒年，因为你刚刚说过了。
So, yeah, 1600 to 1649 and of course famously you know shorter at the end of his reign than all of which badinage suggests Ted that you as well and maybe more on the Cromwellian opinion on this
所以，是的，1600年至1649年，当然，正如大家所熟知的，在他统治末期，他的寿命比所有这些玩笑话都在暗示的要短。泰德，这也表明你可能同样甚至更加倾向于克伦威尔派的观点。
more seriously I think you know there is um i was very interested when i i was sort of um you know uh poking the bear a bit by asking your listeners you know what questions that they would like to ask uh about the trial of charles the first and one person responded what circle of hell do the regicides currently reside in? Would this have been a Mr. Capple loft? It wasn't, in fact. It was another one of your listeners. And it is remarkable, really, given this is an event that happened in 1649.
更严肃地说，我认为，当我在挑起事端、询问听众们想就查理一世的审判提出什么问题时，我感到非常有趣。其中一位听众回答说：“弑君者目前住在地狱的第几层？”这该不会是卡普洛夫先生（Mr. Capple Loft）吧？事实上并不是。那是你的另一位听众。鉴于这是一起发生在1649年的事件，这真的很引人注目。
There clearly is some, you know, that level of strong feeling still about it. But I think it's a case of, you know, as Thomas Paine said, pitying the plumage and not the bird. This is a man who was responsible for the deaths of, you know, tens of thousands of his subjects. And he fitted in many respects, you know, the classical definition of a tyrant. Those charges of being a tyrant, a murderer, you know, a public enemy um these are all charges that could be substantiated so he got what he deserved really oh ted strong views but we should you know for the point of balance from the point of balance point out that absolutely so so this is going out
显然，对于这件事仍然存在那种程度的强烈情感。但我想这就如托马斯·潘恩（Thomas Paine）所说，怜惜羽毛而不怜惜小鸟。这是一个应对成千上万名子民的死负有责任的人。在许多方面，他符合暴君的经典定义。那些被称为暴君、杀人犯、公敌的指控……这些都是有据可查的罪名，所以他确实死有应顾，真的。哦，泰德，你的观点很犀利，但为了保持平衡，我们应该指出……完全同意。所以，这期节目播出的
the week where his death is commemorated yes at church services yes you know he's commemorated as a saint he wasn't a martyr either milton was absolutely right about that he's a faux martyr too let's just let's really wind your listeners up including members of the society for you know okay well i think i well we're not the bbc so we can we can be as biased as we like. But just just for the sake of balance, we should point out that we certainly do have listeners. Kappel Loft, preeminent among them, who are very, very passionate about this. And Dominic Kappel Loft berated us, didn't he, for not including Charles I in the list of the World Cup kings, the World Cup kings. So there is a broad range of opinion. And Ted, I mean, I guess when we're talking about a civil war, that's unsurprising. So could you, maybe for people who aren't British or people who are British who don't know very much about it, just very quickly, what was the civil war what's going on about the war of the two the three kings i mean it's so complex we don't even know what to call it yeah let's call it the english
那一周正好是纪念他忌辰的日子，是的，在教堂礼拜中，是的，他被当作圣人来纪念。他也不是什么殉道者，弥尔顿在这点上完全正确，他也是个伪殉道者。让我们好好激怒一下你的听众，包括那些社会协会的成员……好吧，我想，我们可不是BBC，所以我们可以随心所欲地带有偏见。但为了保持平衡，我们应该指出，我们的确有一些听众——卡普洛夫就是其中最杰出的代表——他们对此非常非常有热情。多米尼克·卡普洛夫严厉斥责了我们，不是吗？因为我们没有将查理一世列入世界杯国王的名单中。因此，大家的观点非常广泛。泰德，我的意思是，当我们谈论内战时，这并不令人意外。所以，能不能为那些不是英国人，或者对这段历史了解不多的英国听众简单介绍一下，内战究竟是怎么回事？三王之战到底是为了什么？这太复杂了，我们甚至不知道该怎么称呼它。好吧，为了讨论方便，我们就叫它英格兰
civil war for the sake of argument with apologies to scottish and irish listeners yeah if we try and focus on england just to sort of keep it as simple as possible i mean that there are so it is a very complicated series of events and so many things behind it and leaning into it. But let's try and focus on a few of them. One is religion. And this is sort of, you know, the aftershocks and after effects of the English Reformation. Charles I's religious policies deeply anger and cause a great deal of fear amongst English Puritans. They see the king and his bishops as trying to reintroduce Catholicism, potpourri, as they call it.
内战吧，向苏格兰和爱尔兰听众道歉。是的，如果我们试着把焦点放在英格兰上，尽量让它保持简单的话，这是一系列非常复杂的事件，背后有那么多的原因和导火索。但让我们试着关注其中的几个。一个是宗教。这可以说是英格兰宗教改革的余波和影响。查理一世的宗教政策激怒了英格兰的清教徒，并让他们感到极大的恐惧。他们认为国王和他的主教们正试图重新引入天主教，也就是他们所说的“教皇迷信”。
So the changes that the king makes in terms of, or his bishops make in terms of the fabric of English churches, the reintroduction of more of a kind of sort of ceremonial and sort of the beauty of holiness, as Charles's Archbishop William Lord calls it, into English churches, all cause a great deal of fear that the king is basically trying to reintroduce Catholicism. And that is exacerbated by the fact that leading Puritans are persecuted by the king, prosecuted for publishing anti-episcopal tracts. So William Prynne famously has his ears cropped twice as a result of publishing hostile works against the king. Well, they trimmed them the first time,
因此，国王或他的主教们对英格兰教堂内部结构所做出的改变，在英格兰教堂中重新引入更多仪式感和查理的主教威廉·劳德（William Laud）所称的“圣洁之美”，所有这些都引发了极大的恐惧，即国王基本上是在试图重新引入天主教。而这一情况由于以下事实而雪上加霜：清教徒领袖遭到国王的迫害，因发表反主教的小册子而被起诉。威廉·普林（William Prynne）就因发表敌视国王的作品而惨遭割耳两次。好吧，第一次他们只是修剪了一下，
and the second time they kind of cut off the stumps. So particularly galling for William Prynne, who was an opponent of long hair as well, he then had to grow his hair to sort of cover up the holes that were left there. The coolest cut of all. Yeah. You know, there's so religious controversies is at the heart of it. And Charles's wife, Henrietta Maria, is Catholic.
第二次他们简直是把残根都切掉了。这对于威廉·普林来说尤其痛苦，他本身也是个反对长发的人，因此他后来不得不留长头发来掩盖留下的洞。最酷炫的发型。是的。宗教争议是这一切的核心。查理的妻子亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚（Henrietta Maria）是天主教徒。
She's Catholic. And so there's a great deal of fear about that and of foreign influence as well. And, you know, there's basis to that, as we see in the Civil War, in that Henrietta Maria is basically Charles I's chief advisor after the death of the Duke of Buckingham. She becomes the most important person at court. But there are also political constitutional issues at play here as well, because Charles has so much difficulty with his parliament that basically he rules without parliament from 1629 up until 1640. So his period of personal rule or the 11 years tyranny, as his critics call it. And these are issues, the issues that he has with his parliament around his foreign policy. They are around the way in which the king is raising money
她是天主教徒。因此，人们对这一点以及外国影响充满了恐惧。而且，正如我们在内战中所看到的，这并非空穴来风，在白金汉公爵死后，亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚基本上成了查理一世首席顾问。她成了宫中最重要的人物。但其中也存在政治和宪政问题，因为查理与议会的关系如此糟糕，以至于他在1629年至1640年间根本不召开议会而直接统治。这就是他的“个人统治时期”，或者被批评者称为“十一年暴政”。这些问题——他与议会之间关于外交政策的问题、国王筹集资金的方式以及他对那些拒绝支付他想要的资金的人采取的手段、他基本上未经审判就实施监禁以及他对待批评者的方式。所以，当时已经有人不仅将国王视为可能试图重新引入天主教的人，而且将其视为以暴君方式统治的人。泰德，我的意思是，国王与议会之争的这种大背景——君主制比议会古老得多——但在某种意义上，难道不是查理才更激进吗？
and what he does with those who refuse to pay the money that he wants, his use of sort of basically imprisonment without trial, and the way that he is dealing with his critics. So there are already people as well who are seeing the king not just as somebody who may be reintroducing, trying to reintroduce Catholicism, but somebody who's ruling in a tyrannical fashion. And Ted, I mean, the general sense of the war of of the king against the parliament the monarchy is much older than the parliament but there is a sense isn't there in which actually it's charles who is the radical yeah isn't he a modernizer in a sense like trying
难道他不是某种意义上的现代化者，试图引入某种专制主义？是这样吗，泰德？是的，他的批评者经常使用的一个词是“革新”。他们把清教徒和那些反对查理一世财政政策的人描绘成现状的捍卫者，而把国王、他的大臣和教会视为革新者，视为那些试图改造国家和教会的人。
to bring in a kind of absolutism is that is that right ted yeah well the the language that's used a lot by his critics is of innovation. And they are very much casting, you know, the Puritans and those who are kind of opponents of Charles I's fiscal policies are very much presenting themselves as the defenders of the status quo with the king, his ministers and the church as the innovators, as those who are trying to transform the state and the church as as the innovators as those who are um trying to transform the state and the church and is that also the the norman yoke and uh the idea of ancestral english freedoms that's kind of bubbling away as well i mean that that certainly comes into play as well that the king is is is challenging that that those rights that are gifted through that ancient constitution um and and yes there is an anxiety too, that is linked to things like, you know, the Queen and her influence, that the King is trying to move England towards a European absolutist Catholic state. And sort of warning signs as well come through court culture too. So Charles is a great collector of art.
而那些试图改造国家和教会的人……这是否也触及了“诺曼枷锁”和祖传英格兰自由的理念？这些思想当时也在暗中涌动。这当然也发挥了作用。国王正在挑战那些通过古老宪法赋予的权利。是的，人们也存在一种与女王及其影响等事物相关的焦虑，即国王正试图将英格兰推向一个欧洲式的专制天主教国家。警示信号也通过宫廷文化显现出来。查理是一位伟大的艺术收藏家。
He spends a lot of money on his court entertainments, these court masks. But a lot of this court aesthetic is the aesthetic of the European absolutist court. and the artworks are artworks that resonate with that kind of political system and also with a more Catholic church as well. Just at the end, so at the end of that period that you talk about, the 11 years personal rule, so before Charles gets into a mess with the Scots and then has to recall Parliament and then you're on the sort of slippery slides of the Civil War.
他在宫廷娱乐上花费了大量金钱，比如这些宫廷假面剧。但这种宫廷美学在很大程度上是欧洲专制宫廷的美学，这些艺术品与那种政治体制以及更倾向天主教的教会产生了共鸣。就在那个时期结束时——也就是你所说的“十一年个人统治”时期结束时——在查理与苏格兰人陷入混乱、不得不重新召集议会、然后走向内战的滑坡路之前，
So before that, just before that, in the late 1630s, is there a sense of sort of slippery slides at the Civil War. So before that, just before that, in the late 1630s, is there a sense of sort of pressure building and people thinking that this is a tyrannical regime? I mean, the sort of broad mass of the public or the broad mass of the public kind of quiescent and just kind of plodding along? Well, it's a weird combination of the two. So you've got sort of, there's no kind of active rebellion and so on. So in one
在这之前，就在那之前，在1630年代末，是否有一种压力在积聚的感觉，人们是否认为这是一个暴政政权？我是说，广大公众是处于顺从状态，还是广大公众基本上是逆来顺受、得过且过？这是一个二者的奇异结合体。所以，并没有那种积极的起义等等。所以在某种
sense, it looks very peaceful. And it then looks like it's sort of, you know, a dramatic, sort of unexpected kind of collapse of this regime, certainly in England, obviously, things already going wrong in Scotland, as you mentioned. But when we look at what people are saying, so yes, you've got, as it were, the kind of machinery of government going on and local government continuing and these taxes that are deeply unpopular, like ship money being administered and collected. But when you look at what... And they're unpopular because they're being levied inland. They're being levied, yeah. so this particular tax is unpopular because traditionally it would have been imposed on maritime counties and only imposed during
意义上，它看起来非常和平。然后它看起来像是这个政权的戏剧性且意料之外的崩溃——当然是在英格兰，显然正如你所提到的，苏格兰的情况已经开始恶化。但当我们看看人们在说些什么时，是的，政府的机器仍在运转，地方政府仍在继续，像船税这样极不受欢迎的税收仍在被征收。然而，当你看到……这些税不受欢迎是因为它们被征收于内陆。它们被征收于……是的。所以这项税不受欢迎是因为传统上它只会被强加给沿海郡县，并且只在
periods of emergency so when there's an invasion threat for example vikings yeah yeah vikings absolutely um so that's but when you so that tax is being collected and being collected by people like Oliver Cromwell. But when we see what some of those people are saying about having to collect this tax, it is that this is deeply worrying that they're having to do this, that it is a sign that this is this is a government which is, you know, operating in a tyrannical fashion. And Ted, I mean, now that there's a lot of kind of whenever anything whenever a government does any measure people say oh this is becoming like hitler i'd be astounded if they were saying it then is there a kind of 17th century equivalent yes where the government does anything and people say oh you know this is like potpourri this is you know we're all going to be you inquis. You'll be pleased to know, Tom, that the comparisons are Roman.
紧急时期征收，比如有入侵威胁的时候——维京人，是的，维京人，绝对是的。所以，这项税正在被征收，而且是由像奥利维尔·克伦威尔这样的人在征收。但当我们看到其中一些人对必须征收这笔税的言论时，他们感到非常担忧，因为他们不得不这样做，这表明这是一个以暴君方式运作的政府。泰德，现在每当政府采取任何举措时，人们都会说“哦，这变得像希特勒了”。如果当时人们也这么说，我会感到震惊。当时有没有17th世纪的等价说法，比如政府做了什么，人们就说“哦，这就像教皇迷信，我们都要被送上宗教法庭了”？汤姆，你可能会高兴地听到，当时的类比是罗马。
So this is like Nero. Yeah. This is Nero. We've been guilty of that as well. There are obviously lots of points in English history where people are disaffected and crossed with, as it were, the government. But often what they do is they say, you know, the king has ill counsel
所以这就像尼禄。是的。这就像尼禄。我们在这一点上也难辞其咎。英国历史上显然有很多时期，人们对政府感到不满和愤怒。但他们通常的做法是说，“国王受到了不良谋士的蛊惑”
or something like that. So in other words, they don't say immediately jump to saying the king is a dreadful tyrant and the most awful person. Is it personalised in that way already in the 1630s, people pointing specifically at Charles? Well, actually, Dominic, could I, sorry, Ted, there's a question from Dave Walters, because actually it's about Charles's character, right? So Dave Walters asks, wasn't major conflict with Parliament inevitable when Charles became king, given his character? And would almost any other monarch of the era have succeeded in keeping more of the people that mattered on side? Yeah, I think Charles's character does play a big role in this. So there is a distinct difference between how James, his father, operates and how Charles operates.
诸如此类的话。换句话说，他们不会立刻跳出来说国王是个可怕的暴君、最糟糕的人。在1630年代，这种针对个人的批评已经出现，人们已经开始直接针对查理了吗？其实，多米尼克，我可以……抱歉，泰德，戴夫·沃特尔斯（Dave Walters）有一个问题，因为这实际上与查理的性格有关，对吧？所以戴夫·沃特尔斯问：鉴于查理的性格，当他成为国王时，与议会的重大冲突难道不是不可避免的吗？而且，那个时代的几乎任何其他君主都能成功地让更多重要人物站在自己这一边吗？是的，我认为查理的性格在这其中起到了很大的作用。他的父亲詹姆斯行事的方式与查理行事的方式有着明显的区别。
So James is much better at, you know, allowing debate and accepting that there will be criticism, that there will be, you know, arguments about policies and so on. Charles has a tendency to see criticism and argument as itself a problem. So actually, if we look at his court culture, whereas what James liked was disputations where he could show off how intellectual he was. What Charles likes is is these kinds of performances, these masks where royalty appears and solves everything. You know, I mean, it's like the fantastic painting of him as some people may see, you know, know the painting of him as St. George besting the dragon. And basically it's the monarch has solved everything. All disputes, all disagreements have been pushed aside.
詹姆斯更擅长允许辩论，并接受会有批评、会有关于政策的争论等等。而查理有一种倾向，他将批评和争论本身视为一个问题。事实上，如果我们看看他的宫廷文化，詹姆斯喜欢的是那种能展现他有多睿智的辩论。而查理喜欢的是这类表演——王室出现并解决一切问题的假面剧。你知道，这就像那幅他把自己画成圣乔治降服恶龙的著名画作，有些人可能见过。基本上就是君主解决了所有问题。所有的争端、所有的分歧都被抛在一边。
And so he can't accept it when there is opposition, when there is disputation about policies. It's not something that he recognises as sort of just part of political life. But in the grand scheme of kind of bad monarchical behaviour, I mean, last time you came on, we were talking about King John, who I think we all agreed is an absolutely terrible man. And you mentioned Nero. Yeah.
因此，当出现反对意见、当对政策存在争议时，他是无法接受的。他并不认为这是政治生活的一部分。但在君主糟糕行为的宏大图景中——上次你来做客时，我们谈到了无地王约翰，我们都认为他是个绝对糟糕的人，你还提到了尼禄。
I mean, Charles I's defenders would presumably say he's a nice family man, you know, he likes paintings, he's not cruel, he's, you know, is he a... Is tyrant the right word? So I think, you know, in comparison to figures like Nero and King John, yes, absolutely, he looks much, much better. But I think, to come back to the question you were asking just before Tom rudely interrupted. Yeah, that was rude. Sorry. I'm sorry. I think the,
查理一世的捍卫者大概会说他是个不错的顾家好男人，他喜欢绘画，他不残酷，他是个……“暴君”这个词准确吗？所以我想，与尼禄和约翰王这样的人物相比，是的，绝对的，他看起来要好得多。但我想，回到你在汤姆粗暴打断我之前提出的那个问题……是的，那是很不礼貌。抱歉。我很抱歉。我认为，
so what is difficult about the evil counsellor's position, which is certainly one that gets used, and certainly in the early years of the civil war, that they're not fighting the king. They're trying, they're trying to actually kind of rescue the king from the clutch of the, of these evil counsellors who are leading him astray. It is that Charles is very obviously, well, with Henrietta Maria, kind of in control of things.
关于“邪恶谋士”立场的难点在于——这确实被用过，尤其是在内战的早期，他们当时并不是在与国王战斗，他们试图做的是把国王从这些将他带入歧途的邪恶谋士的魔爪中拯救出来——但事实是，查理非常明显地（与亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚一起）掌控着一切。
And there is, I mean, for one thing, his main favourite prior to Henrietta Maria, the Duke of Buckingham has been bumped off. And there's no other figure who really replaces him in Stratford, his Lord Deputy in Ireland, to a certain extent. But it's really the king and the queen who seem to be kind of running the show and dictating things. So it's quite hard to sort of say, oh, well, somebody else is actually, you know, driving this and to blame. It's a bit it already feels a bit artificial from that point of view.
而且，一方面，在亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚之前他最喜欢的宠臣白金汉公爵已经被干掉了。在斯特拉福德（他在爱尔兰的副总督）之外，没有其他人能真正取代他的位置，不过到了一定程度是这样的。但实际上是国王和王后在发号施令、掌控一切。所以很难说“哦，其实是另一个人在幕后操纵并应当承担责任”。从那个角度来看，这已经让人感觉有点做作了。
And then when you look at this criticism that's going on in the 1630s you have you know you already have got people like prin who was saying albeit in a kind of you know allegorical and trying to sort of you know not immediately direct way they're already making these connections between um charles and classical tyrants they. They're not sort of saying, oh, it's somebody else. It is already, you know, Charles who is the problem that is being identified. And the second part of Dave Walter's question, would almost any other monarch of the era have succeeded
然后当你看看1630年代的这种批评时，你已经有了像普林这样的人——尽管是以一种寓言式的、试图不那么直接的方式——他们已经在查理和古代暴君之间建立起了联系。他们并没有说“哦，是别人干的”。被指认为问题的根源、已经被明确指出的正是查理本人。戴夫·沃特尔斯问题的第二部分：那个时代的几乎任何其他君主都能成功地让更多重要人物站在自己这一边吗？我是说，你能想象吗？我认为后半句对查理更严厉。君主面临着巨大的问题，任何君主都会面临这些问题。其中包括一个半改革的教会，其中有相当一部分人希望它变得更加新教化，而其他人则不希望它向加尔文派风格的教会迈进得太远。
in keeping more of the people that mattered on side? I mean, could you imagine? I think that one is harsher on Charles. There are big problems that, you know, the monarch is facing, any monarch would be facing. And those a church that is half reformed with, you know, significant sections that want it to become much more Protestant and others who don't want it to move that far towards a more Calvinist style of church. problem created by the union of crowns of governing multiple kingdoms and kingdoms with very different religious establishments as well. And you've got the problem of the fact that the, you know, the financial stability of the monarchy has been an issue through the reigns of Elizabeth and through the reigns of James as well but so it is not an easy inheritance couldn't the counter be that as you say he inherits a lot of these problems from elizabeth and james um but both of them were unpopular at times but they managed to base it they were more skillful and also his son charles ii faces not dissimilar
由联合王冠统治多个王国以及拥有非常不同宗教建制的王国所带来的问题。而且你还有这样一个问题：从伊丽莎白统治时期到詹姆斯统治时期，君主制的财政稳定一直是个问题，所以这不是一个轻松的传承。难道人们不会反驳说，正如你所说，他继承了伊丽莎白和詹姆斯的很多问题，但他们两人在某些时候也很不受欢迎，不过他们设法应付过去了，他们更有手腕？而且他的儿子查理二世也面临着并非不同的问题，并且也没有被处决。所以查理肯定是做错了什么。是的，他的确做错了。至于他是否继承了许多问题……是的，他确实继承了很多问题，但正是查理及其性格和决策，在很大程度上将事情推向了1649年这一非同寻常的结局。好吧。好的，我们必须推进到那一步。
problems and also is not executed so So Charles is doing something wrong. Yes, he is. The question as to, you know, yes, he has, you know, inherits a lot of issues, but it is Charles and his character and his decision-making which plays a large part in bringing things to this extraordinary conclusion in 1649. Right. Okay, which we have to get to.
是的。让我们快速浏览一下。你精彩阐述的危机状态最终导致了内战。议会与国王之间爆发了战争。战争以国王的战败告终。这看起来似乎是定局。但我们随后迎来了斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark，节目之友）的问题。在1645年6月的第一次英格兰内战中，新模范军在纳斯比大败敌军之后……所以，新模范军嘛，它是新的。它是一支模范军队。它是一支新模范军。
Yes. So let's just speed through. So everything, the state of crisis that you've brilliantly set out leads in the long run to civil war. And war rages between Parliament and King. And it ends with the King's defeat. And that looks to be conclusive. But we then have a question
精彩的评论，汤姆。顶级的17世纪分析。它尤其与克伦威尔联系在一起。在1645年6月的第一次英格兰内战中被新模范军在纳斯比大败之后，为什么查理一世还要在1648年冒着风险对他们发动第二次内战？嗯，这才是这个故事的关键，不是吗？事实上，他被视为挑起者。第二次内战到底是怎么回事？
from Stephen Clark, friend of the show. After heavy defeat by the new model army at Naseby. So the new model army is, well, it's new. It's a model army. It's a new model army.
那么，这再次回到了查理的性格上，他总是试图让对手互相争斗，而不是真诚地谈判。
Brilliant punditry, Tom. Top 17th century analysis there. And it's particularly associated with Cromwell. After heavy defeat by the New Model Army at Naseby in June 1645 in the First English Civil War, why did Charles I risk a second civil war against them in 1648? Well, that's key to this story, isn't it? The fact that he's seen as triggering. So what's going on with the second civil War? So, well, I think this is, again, comes back to Charles's character, is that he's always trying to play his opponents off each other rather than negotiating good faith.
他总是在寻找恢复权力的方法，基本上就是回到内战前的现状。他真地不想在自己的权力方面做出任何让步，所以他与苏格兰立约派所达成的那个所谓的“妥协协议”，就是他摆脱困境的一种方式。告诉我们苏格兰立约派是什么人。立约派就是那些在1630年代反对查理一世及其在苏格兰的宗教政策的人。他们结成了这个“国民立约”，（反对那些政策）。但他们同时也是保皇派，
And he's always looking for a way to recover, basically to go back to the status quo before the civil war he doesn't really want to concede anything in terms of his his authority um and so the the engagement as it's called that he makes with the scottish covenanters is a way for him to do that to basically get out of it tells tell us who the Scottish Covenanters are. So the Covenanters are the people who have been opponents of Charles I in the 1630s and opposed to his religious policies in Scotland. And they form this national covenant, you know, against those policies. But they are also monarchists. so they they're also opposed to the establishment of a republic and they form this this alliance although it's one that actually splits the covenant of cause
所以他们也反对建立共和国，他们结成了这个联盟——尽管这个联盟实际上导致立约派内部产生分裂，并引发了第二次内战。所以泰德，我的理解是否正确：在查理……查理在第一次内战结束时被逼入绝境并被俘虏了——好吧，他投靠了苏格兰人，对吧？是的，他们把他卖给了议会。但有一个时间点，基本上——我对所有不同的派别并不是特别清楚——有苏格兰人，有议会中想要与查理达成协议的人，还有那些名义上对议会负责、但现在有了自己议程的军队。这基本上是对的吗？
to and which which leads to the the second civil war so basically am i right in thinking ted that after charles so charles was cornered at the end of the first civil war and he was captured well he gave him he he went over to the scots didn't he yes they sold him to parliament but there's a point at which there are basically i'm not massively clear on all the different factions but there's the scots there's some people in parliament who want to do a deal with Charles, and then there's the army who are supposedly answerable to Parliament, but have now got their own agenda. Is that basically right?
英格兰人民的武装力量。是的，基本就是这样。因此，第一次内战结束后的局势是，国王成了阶下囚，但在不同的阶段，他是不同派别的阶下囚。他最初是立约派的阶下囚，正如你所说，然后成了议会的阶下囚。接着，在一个相当戏剧性和非同寻常的事件中，他被一个非常低阶的军官——科内特·乔伊斯（Cornet Joyce）代表军队劫持，落入了军队的控制之中。国王问科内特·乔伊斯他的权力来自哪里，乔伊斯指了指他身后的其他士兵，你可以
The armed wing of the English people. Yeah, that's basically it. So the situation sort of post-First Civil War is that the king is a prisoner, but he's a prisoner of different factions at different points. So he starts off as a prisoner of the Covenants, as you say, then becomes Parliament's prisoner. Then in a rather dramatic and extraordinary instance, he's seized by a very lowly officer, Cornet Joyce, for the army and taken into the army's custody. The king asked Cornet Joyce what his authority is joyce points at the other soldiers behind him and you
从两个方面来理解这一点：他要么是在说“闭嘴吧，我身后的这群家伙带着火枪呢”，要么是在说军队就是我的权力来源。是的，我们自己拥有权力。是的，确实存在这三个不同的党派。事实上，军队与议会之间日益加深的互不信任在这里也至关重要。因为军队中的许多普通士兵担心的是，议会和军队领导层都会通过一份温和的和解协议来出卖他们。他们基本上要与国王缔结和平协议，这意味着他们无法免于因内战中的所作所为而被起诉的风险，
can read that in two ways he's either saying shut up i've got some guys with with muskets with me or the army is my authority yeah we have the authority ourselves um so yes there are these three different parties um and actually also the growing distrust between the army and parliament is critical here, because what's a lot of the rank and file in the army fear is that both parliament and also the army leadership are going to sell them out with a soft peace. They are basically going to conclude a peace with the king, which will mean that they're not protected from being prosecuted for what they've done in the civil war um and and that is something that they are very worried about that you know that they'll basically do a deal with charles i and then charles i will go back on that and they'll you know be strung up so charles um when does he get taken to carisbrook Castle on the Isle of Wight? So what happens is actually that Charles escapes from Hampton Court.
这是他们非常担心的事情，他们担心议会基本上会与查理一世达成交易，然后查理一世会出尔反反，把他们统统吊死。那么，查理什么时候被带到怀特岛的卡里斯布鲁克城堡的呢？其实发生的事情是查理从汉普顿宫逃跑了。
And the reason why he is driven to escape is important as well, because during the Putney debates, which are mostly famous for this discussion over the right to vote. So this is the New Model Army. The New Model Army and civilian levellers discussing the agreements to the people and the case of the army, these radical documents, talking about every man having the right to vote, the poorest he has much of life to live is the greatest he, as Thomas Rainsborough says.
他被迫逃跑的原因也很重要，因为在普特尼辩论期间——这场辩论主要以关于投票权的讨论而闻名。这就是新模范军。新模范军和平民平等派讨论了《人民协议》和军队的案件，这些激进的文件谈到每个人都有投票权的权利，“穷人也有生命要过，这才是最伟大的”，正如托马斯·雷恩斯伯勒（Thomas Rainsborough）所说。
But what also gets discussed at Putney is what to live as the greatest tea as thomas rainsborough says um but what also gets discussed at putney is what to do with the king and a couple of officers one of whom thomas harrison goes on to become a regicide himself call charles the first yeah friend of the show he's the one who um we mentioned in the um yes dies very, dies very cheerfully. Yes. So he's a fifth monarchist man. Fifth monarchist. He calls Charles I a man of blood and says that the king must be proceeded against as a man of blood.
但在普特尼被讨论的还有如何处置国王的问题，其中有几位军官——其中一位托马斯·哈里森（Thomas Harrison）后来自己成了弑君者，称查理一世为……是的，节目之友，他就是我们提到的那个……是的，死得非常豁达。是的，他是个第五王国的信徒。第五王国派。他称查理一世为血腥之徒，并说必须作为血腥之徒对国王进行审判。
So there is already talk late 1647 in the army about putting the king on trial. And Charles hears about this via john lilburn who is a prisoner in the tower at this point in time but a prisoner with royalist prisoners and word reaches charles i at hampton court about the you know these kinds of statements that are being made about his fate and decides it's time to do a runner basically and not you know but at that point ted that must be a very is that not perceived why generally it's a very
所以早在1647年底，军队内部就已经在讨论审判国王了。查理通过约翰·利尔本（John Lilburn）听说了这件事，利尔本当时是塔中的囚犯，但与保皇派囚犯关在一起，汉普顿宫的查理一世听到了关于人们对他的命运做出这类声明的风声，于是基本上决定是时候开溜了，而不是……但在那个时候，泰德，这难道不会被普遍认为是一个非常极端和激进的立场吗？试图处决国王，因为第二次内战还没有发生，所以查理还没有完全彻底地自我声誉扫地。因此，军队和议会中的大多数人会认为“这太疯狂了，我们显然不会审判他”，还是有相当多的人说“不，这是对的，他必须走”？所以就军队领导层而言，你是对的，克伦威尔实际上反对哈里森，他们基本上就《圣经》的解释进行了争论。所以“血腥之徒”这个词扎根于《旧约》，扎根于《创世记》和《民数记》。其理念基本上是，流血者，必须通过流洗谋杀者的血来平息这种血债，以平息上帝的愤怒。但克伦威尔对哈里森的回应是，不，不，不，对这段经文有不同的解释。事实上，这是一段可以关于道德告诫而不是处决人的经文。所以可以肯定的是，当时军队的领导层正试图反驳这种观点。但你可以看到，甚至在第一次内战刚结束的余波中，普通士兵中间的愤怒也在不断增长。据报道，有普通士兵将查理称为“亚哈”（Ahab），也将亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚称为“耶洗别”（Jezebel）。所以在第一次内战刚结束时，那种对他的愤怒程度，已经将他视为一个必须被清除的邪恶国王。
extreme and radical position to try and execute the king because the second civil war hasn't happened so charles hasn't completely sort of as it were disgraced himself further yet so to most people in the army and in parliament think well that's bonkers we're obviously not going to try him or are there quite a lot of people who say no that's right he's got to go so in terms of the army leadership you're you're right and cromwell is actually argues against harrison he says and they basically have an argument over the biblical interpretation so this phrase man of blood is is rooted in the Old Testament, rooted in the book of Genesis and the book of Numbers. It's the idea that basically he who
所以查理随后做出逃跑、密谋、表现糟糕等决定，实际上是极其愚蠢的。所以，是的，再次说明，去怀特岛是一个糟糕的决定。他决定逃往怀特岛，因为他认为那里的总督罗伯特·哈蒙德（Robert Hammond）对怀有好感，会帮他逃往欧洲大陆，但事实上他并没有这么做，而是把他关在那里。那是卡里斯布鲁克城堡。卡里斯布鲁克城堡，他曾有几次试图从卡里斯布鲁克城堡逃跑。他试图钻过去的那扇窗户现在还在。是的。
spills blood, the guilt of that blood must be assuaged by the shedding of the murderer's blood in order to assuage God's wrath. But what Cromwell says in answer to Harrison is, no, no, no, there's different ways of interpreting that text. And actually, it's a text that can be about moral admonition rather than, you know, putting people to death. So certainly, the army leadership at this point in time is trying to argue against that view. But you can see even, you know, in the immediate aftermath of the First Civil War, growing anger amongst the rank and file. There are members of the rank and file who reportedly refer to Charles as Ahab as well, making Henrietta Maria his Jezebel too. So there's already in the wake of the First Civil War, that level of anger against him,
结果极其滑稽地失败了。他卡在了窗户里。
a way of seeing him as this sort of wicked king who must be done away with. So it's actually incredibly foolish of Charles to then take the decisions like running away, plotting, behaving badly. So, yeah, again, it's a bad decision to go to the Isle of Wight. He decides to flee to the Isle of Wight because he thinks that the governor there um Robert Hammond is sympathetic to him and will help him escape uh to the continent but in fact he doesn't do that and locks him up there uh and he's really Carisbrook Castle Carisbrook Castle and he makes a couple of attempts to to escape from Carisbrook Castle the window that he tried to get through is still there. Yes. Which are comically unsuccessful. He gets stuck in the window.
第二次尝试时，他带着硝酸和钢锯，试图锯开铁栏杆，结果在锯到一半的时候被抓了个正现。
And the second attempt he's, he's, he's trying to, um, uh, he's got nitric acid and a hacksaw and he tries to sort of trying to cut open the bars and gets caught halfway, you know,
不过这对查理来说也算公平了。我是说，他以前没有任何越狱经验。对吧？是的，这很公平。我是说，他之前只是坐在那里看假面剧。是的，他不是一个经验丰富的越狱高手。他不是17世纪的杰克·谢泼德（Jack Sheppard）。所以他被困在卡里斯布鲁克城堡里越狱失败。与此同时，英格兰重陷内战的情况如何呢？
in, in, in mid sort of hack. But it's fair to Charles. I mean, he's got no prior experience of escape. No, he's not.
所以，是的，他被困在卡里斯布鲁克。他签署了那个妥协协议。一当这个协议的消息传到一直试图与国王谈判的议会时，议会便中断了谈判。所以这个协议，抱歉，是与苏格兰人达成的。是与苏格兰立约派达成的。并发表了一份非常惊人的声明，
That's fair. I mean, he's just been sitting around watching Charles. I mean, he's got no prior experience of escape attempts, right? No, he's not. That's fair. I mean, he's just been sitting around watching masks. Yeah, not an experienced jailbreaker. He's not a kind of Houdini figure. Not a Jack Shepard of the 17th century. So he's in Carisbrook Castle failing to escape. And meanwhile, what is happening with the return of England to civil war?
宣布不再接受来自国王的任何陈情，不再为国王举行个人条约谈判。在这份声明中，它指控查理犯下各种可怕的罪行，包括通过使用毒药掩盖白金汉公爵谋杀其父亲詹姆斯一世的行径。因此，它甚至entertain（抱持）了关于国王的最不可思议的阴谋论。所以这似乎让查理一世的处境看起来更加糟糕，议会正在发表这类声明。
So, yes, so he's in Carisbrook. He's entered into this engagement. As soon as the news of the engagement reaches Parliament, which has been, you know, trying to negotiate with the king, it breaks off these negotiations. So the engagement, sorry, is with the Scots. Is with the Scottish Covenanters. And issues a very remarkable declaration
第二次内战本身对保皇派和立约派来说进展得非常糟糕。威尔士爆发了起义，肯特爆发了起义，这是最严重的几次。苏格兰立约派发动了入侵。立约派在普雷斯顿战役中被克伦威尔的军队彻底击溃。也是克伦威尔平息了威尔士的叛乱。费尔法克斯平息了肯特的叛乱。科尔切斯特有一场非常残酷的围城战，费尔法克斯也亲自指挥了这场战役。最终，他们在1648年8月底投降，两名保皇派指挥官被迅速处决，这再次表明了冲突过程中人们的态度的确变得更加强硬。所以保皇派被打败了。我认为第二次内战在这里确实具有极其关键的意义，因为它做了一件非常重要的事情，那就是它改变了军队指挥官的态度。正如我刚才在普特尼所说，克伦威尔当时还在反对起诉国王。我认为到了最后，
that it will have no further addresses from the king, there'll be no further personal treaty for the king, in which declaration it accuses Charles of all sorts of terrible crimes, including covering up the murder of his father, James I, by the Duke of Buckingham through the use of poisons. So it entertains the most extraordinary conspiracy theories about the king. So that seems to sort of, you know, make things look even worse for Charles I, that Parliament is making these kinds of statements.
国王将不再收到来自议会的任何训词，也不会再有针对国王的个人条约。该宣言指控查理犯有一系列可怕的罪行，包括通过白金汉公爵使用毒药来掩盖其父詹姆斯一世的谋杀案。因此，它接受了关于国王的最非同寻常的阴谋论。这似乎让查理一世的处境看起来更加糟糕，因为议会正在发表此类声明。
The Second Civil War itself goes very badly for the royalists and the covenanters. So there are risings in Wales, there are risings in Kent, they're the most serious ones. There's a Covenanter invasion. The Covenanters are crushed at the Battle of Preston by Cromwell's forces. It's also Cromwell who suppresses the rebellion in Wales. Fairfax suppresses the rebellion in Kent. There's a really nasty siege in Colchester, which Fairfax is also in command of. Finally, they surrender at the end of August 1648, and two of the royalist commanders are summarily executed, which is, again, a sign of how things have hardened, attitudes have hardened during the course of this conflict. So the royalists are defeated. And I think that's there is some really the Second Civil War is really pivotal in this because it does something really important, which is it changes the attitude of the army command. So whereas I said in Putney, we've got Cromwell arguing against prosecuting the king. I think by the end of the
第二次英国内战本身对保王党人和苏格兰立约派来说进展得非常不顺利。威尔士发生了起义，肯特也发生了起义，这些是最严重的起义。苏格兰立约派发动了入侵，但他们在普雷斯顿战役中被克伦威尔的军队击溃。也是克伦威尔镇压了威尔士的叛乱，费尔法克斯镇压了肯特的叛乱。科尔切斯特有一场非常残酷的围城战，费尔法克斯也亲自指挥了这场战斗。最终，他们在1648年8月底投降，两名保王党指挥官被即决处决，这再次表明了在这场冲突的过程中，局势和态度是如何变得越发强硬的。因此，保王党战败了。我认为第二次英国内战确实至关重要，因为它做了一件非常关键的事，那就是它改变了军队指挥层的态度。正如我在普特尼所说的那样，克伦威尔曾反对起诉国王，但我认为到了……结束时
Second Civil War, he has become convinced that Charles has to be prosecuted. He says that Charles is a man against whom the Lord has witnessed. You know, God has made his judgment against the king. And now it is time that the king is dealt with. Just before we carry on, I think it's time for a quick break. In the name of God, go. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
第二次内战，他已经确信必须起诉查理。他说，查理是一个遭到上天见证的人。你知道，上帝已经对国王做出了判决。现在是时候处置国王了。在我们继续之前，我想是时候休息一下了。以上帝之名，走吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少许娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to part two of today's episode of The Rest Is History. We are discussing Charles I, his trial, his execution with Professor Ted Valance. The Royalists have been now conclusively and decisively and publicly defeated in the eyes of God. That's how I guess everyone on the parliamentarian side sees it. But the problem remains that the king is not the kind of man to accept compromise. So I guess that there are various options one you try and persuade the king to accept the kind of compromises that you as a parliamentarian want that presumably doesn't work well because charles is digging his heels in he feels that god wants him to defend bishops and all the kind of all that kind of stuff. So there's no real prospect of negotiation there.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到今天《历史的其余部分》节目的第二部分。我们将与特德·瓦伦斯教授一起讨论查理一世、他的审判以及他的处决。在上帝眼中，保王党现在已经被彻底、决定性且公开地击败了。我想议会派的每个人都是这么看的。但问题依然存在，国王不是那种会接受妥协的人。所以我想有几种选择，一种是你试图说服国王接受你作为议会派所希望的那种妥协，据推测这并管用，因为查理顽固不化，他觉得上帝要他去保卫主教以及所有诸如此类的事情。所以在那里没有什么真正的谈判前景。
The other option, I mean, one that has happened throughout English history, is that where you have a problematic king, whether it's Richard II or Henry VI or whatever, you dispose of him and you come up with a new king. Is there no thought of doing that? Yeah, there certainly is thought of doing that. So the most likely candidate for that option that you're talking about is Charles's youngest son, Henry. And Henry is in Parliament's custody at this point. And he's eight, isn't he?
另一种选择，我的意思是，英格兰历史上一直都有发生的一种情况，那就是当你有一个麻烦的国王，不管是理查二世还是亨利六世或其他什么人，你处理掉他，然后换一个新的国王。难道就没有人考虑过这么做吗？是的，当然有人考虑过。所以你所说的那个选项中最有可能的人选是查理的小儿子亨利。而此时亨利在议会的监管之下。他才八岁，对吧？
Yeah. So the thinking is that he could be, he's young enough that he could be sort of trained up to be a sort of parliamentarian puppet king, you know, with very limited power, if any power. But that is certainly one option that seems to be being entertained. the king is executed because you know henry remains um in parliament's custody uh after the execution um and he does actually become a kind of very hot protestant doesn't he yeah he ends up with his mother and they can't get on at all so so why do they not go with him um well i i think ultimately um the i mean i think there's a few things here one obviously we we move as we go through the 1650s into a situation where effectively it becomes a kind of cromwellian dynasty instead and so so that you know we're moving away um from that i think the other thing is that there there is um a sense in which this becomes about more than doing away with a wicked king yeah okay so that's the third option isn't it that you and you decide that this it's not just the king that's being judged but the
对。所以人们的想法是，他可以，他年龄还小，可以被培养成一种议会傀儡国王，你知道的，权力非常有限，甚至没有权力。但这确实是一个似乎正在被考虑的选择。国王被处决了，因为你知道，亨利在处决后仍然在议会的监管之下，而且他实际上确实变成了一个相当狂热的新教徒，对吧？是的，他最后和他的母亲在一起，他们根本合不来，所以他们为什么不选他呢？嗯，我猜最终，我的意思是，我觉得这里有几件事，显而易见的是，随着我们进入1650年代，我们进入了一种实际上变成了克伦威尔式王朝的情况，所以你知道，我们正在远离这一点，我认为另一件事是，某种程度上，这不仅仅是关于除掉一个邪恶的国王。好吧，那就是第三个选项了，对吧？你决定这不仅是对国王的审判，
whole institution of monarchy it is monarchy that is the problem it is it is the monarchy fundamentally leads to this sort of corrupt oppressive form but that is a very very very radical position i mean it's not a position i mean i don't know how many people held that position at the start of the civil war in early 1640s but not many i would have thought um yeah Yeah. How radical a position is it in the summer of 1648 as the commanders of the army are trying to work out what to do? How radical a position is that in the context of England as a whole? Yes, it remains a very radical position. It remains a very radical position.
而是对整个君主制机构的审判，君主制才是问题所在，君主制从根本上导致了这种腐败、压迫的形式，但这一个非常、非常、非常激进的立场。我的意思是，这并不是一个立场，我的意思是，我不知道在内战爆发之初、即1640年代早期有多少人持有这种立场，但我想没有多少人，嗯，是的。在1648年夏天，当军队指挥官们正试图弄清楚该做什么的时候，这是一个多么激进的立场？在整个英格兰的背景下，这是一个多么激进的立场？是的，它依然是一个非常激进的立场。它依然是一个非常激进的立场。
And I think it's even more radical because at this point in time, it is increasingly, we're not talking about the kind of aristocratic republicanism that could be seen as a Venetian form of republicanism. It is a republicanism that is being grounded in ideas of popular sovereignty. There's a kind of leveller-infused republicanism. And so there's a great deal of anxiety about that. I mean, just as an example of this, the royalist diarist John Evelyn sneaks into the Whitehall debates of December 1648,
而且我认为它甚至更加激进，因为在这个时间点上，它越来越不再是我们所讨论的那种可以被视为威尼斯式共和主义的贵族共和主义。这是一种植根于人民主权思想的共和主义。这是一种融入了平等派思想的共和主义。因此，人们对此有着极大的焦虑。我的意思是，作为一个例子，保王派日记作家约翰·伊夫林潜入了1648年12月的白厅辩论，
which is the army sitting again with civilian levellers discussing, you know, what to do, how to settle the kingdom. And he talks about the horrid villainies that are discussed at the Whitehall debates. So he's shocked by the matter of what is being discussed. But the thing that also really shocks him is what he describes as the raw, ill-mannered young men who are speaking there. So what Evelyn is also scandalised by is by the fact that these are young men, young lower class men, who are speaking to their social betters as if there were no distinctions of class between them, who are speaking as if there's nothing that should stop them from taking control.
那是军队再次与平民平等派坐在一起讨论，你知道，该做什么，如何安定王国。他谈到了在白厅辩论中讨论的那些可怕的罪行。所以他对正在讨论的事情感到震惊。但真正令他震惊的，还有他所描述的那些在那里发言的粗俗、举止恶劣的年轻男子。所以伊夫林同样感到愤怒的事实是，这些都是年轻人，社会地位低下的年轻人，他们与他们社会上更优越的人对话时，就好像他们之间没有阶级区别一样，他们说话的口气仿佛没有什么能阻止他们夺取控制权。
And is that what makes this different from, say, if a similar event had happened 100 years previously? I mean, you had, I don't know, the Pilgrimage of Grace or something where there's a kind of real culture of kind of deference still to Henry VIII, even though people are outraged by his religious policy. Is that something that has changed by the, partly because of, I don't know, is it because of literacy and prints and all these kinds of things? Yeah, I think so.
这是否就是让这一切变得与比如说100年前发生类似事件时不同的地方？我的意思是，你曾有过，我不知道，恩典朝圣之类的活动，那里对亨利八世仍然有一种真正的顺从文化，尽管人们对他的宗教政策感到愤怒。这是由于某些原因而在当时发生改变的事情吗，部分是因为，我不知道，是因为识字率和印刷品以及所有这些类型的东西吗？是的，我认为是的。
Because, and I think that is something where the Civil War itself, because of the things you're talking about in terms of the explosion, sort of printed news reporting, this sort of greater literacy to kind of absorb that material. This is something where there has been a kind of real radicalising effect on the population, particularly on soldiers within the New Model Army over the course of the 1640s. Right. So, Ted, could we now go into the process by which charles is brought to trial and then ultimately to the block um so while while cromwell is away the army are basically kind of self-radicalizing perhaps and they and they come up with something called the um the remonstrance of General Fairfax and the Council of Officers.
因为，我认为这也是内战本身所带来的影响，因为你所谈论的关于爆炸性增长的那种印刷新闻报道，这种吸收这些材料的更高识字率。随着1640年代的推移，这对民众、特别是新模范军内部的士兵产生了一种真正的激进化的影响。没错。那么，特德，我们现在能否探讨一下查理被送上审判并最终走上断头台的过程呢？嗯，所以当克伦威尔不在的时候，军队基本上在某种程度上自我激进化了，他们提出了一个名为托马斯·费尔费克斯将军和军官委员会的抗议书的东西。
So just tell us what that is, because that's very important, isn't it? It is. So it's largely drafted by Henry Ireton, Cromwell's son-in-law, also a significant leader of the New Model Army. But with input from some of these civilian levellers as well. And it is a lengthy kind of indictment of Charles, and it demands that, effectively it demands that the king should be brought to justice. Now, this is a very long document as well as about 25 000 words it's read in full to parliament so it takes several hours to do that as you can manage the other few mps probably nodding off during the yeah you know uh during the reading although i suppose i
所以给我们讲讲那是什么，因为这非常重要，不是吗？是的。所以它主要是由亨利·伊雷顿起草的，他是克伦威尔的女婿，也是新模范军的重要领导人。但同时也吸收了其中一些平民平等派的意见。这是一份对查理的冗长控诉，它要求，实际上它要求将国王绳之以法。现在，这是一份非常长的文件，大约有25000字，它被完整地宣读给议会，所以这需要几个小时的时间，你可以想象其他少数议员可能在宣读过程中打瞌睡，你知道，嗯，在宣读过程中，虽然我想
mean it's so explosive in its implications that perhaps yes yes so yeah so so there yes i think i think probably attention was was was you know there wasn't any problem with that during during the reading um and you know it is met with with great consternation uh by parliament becomes very clear that parliament is not going to um accept uh that call to bring the king to justice. And so that then moves the army to another solution, which is basically to purge Parliament of those members who are not going to support bringing the king to trial in what's known as Pride's Purge, after the commander Thomas Pride, who with his guard of troops prevents these MPs who've been identified as moderates from entering the chamber. Some of them are just dismissed and some of them are put into
我的意思是，它的隐含意义是如此具有爆发力，以至于也许，是的，是的，所以，是的，所以我想，可能注意力，你知道的，在宣读期间没有任何问题，而且你知道的，它遭到了议会的极大惊愕，人们非常清楚议会将不会接受将国王绳之以法的呼吁。因此，这促使军队走向了另一个解决方案，基本上就是清洗议会将那些不支持审判国王的议员排除在外，这就是所谓的“普莱德清洗”，以指挥官托马斯·普莱德的名字命名，他带着一队士兵阻止这些被认定为温和派的议员进入议会大厅。其中一些人直接被解雇，另一些人则被拘留。
custody. So this is basically a coup. I mean, that's what it is. Yes. And it is also something I think we should emphasise that actually been talked about in the army as well before. So it is not the army, figures in the army have been talking about purging parliament for some time, because, as I said, parliament had become seen as being increasingly suspect as well. And how do they justify that, Ted? Because they can't claim there's any constitutional basis. Do they claim, is there a kind of religious justification for that they're doing god's work or something no i think that the justification is primarily political and it is that these mps
所以这基本上是一场政变。我的意思是，这就是它的本质。是的。这也是我们应该强调的一点，其实军队以前也讨论过这一点。所以这并不是军队，军队中的一些人物一段时间以来一直在谈论清洗议会，因为正如我所说，议会也开始被视为越来越可疑。特德，他们是如何为之辩护的？因为他们不能声称有任何宪法依据。他们是否声称，是否存在某种宗教辩护，证明他们在做上帝的工作或类似的事情？不，我认为这种辩护主要是政治性的，那就是这些议员
are of suspect loyalty that these mps are people who are you know disaffected um who are who are quasi royalist so would it be would it be fair to say that i I mean, the trial of Charles I, that in a way, it's not really about his crimes, whether he's guilty of crimes, even whether he should be put to death. But it's about who has political legitimacy, what the source of political legitimacy is. And that's essentially what's at stake. And anyone who stands in the way of the army declaring that they have the political legitimacy basically have to be purged, whether it's the monarchy or whether it's traditionalist parliamentarians. Yeah. And that's made very clear in a declaration of the commons on January the 4th, where they basically say, you know, we are the sovereign power as representatives of the people, not the king, not the lords. Now, there's an expedient reason for this, which is that the
的忠诚度令人怀疑，这些议员是那些你知道的、心怀不满的人，是那些准保王派的人。那么这样说是否公平，我的意思是，对查理一世的审判，在某种程度上，其实并不是关于他的罪行，他是否犯有罪行，甚至他是否应该被处死。而是关于谁拥有政治合法性，政治合法性的来源是什么。这本质上才是处于利害关系中的核心。而任何阻碍军队宣布他们拥有政治合法性的人基本上都必须被清洗，无论是君主制还是传统主义议会议员。是的。这在1月4日下议院的一份宣言中说得很清楚，他们基本上说，你知道，我们作为人民的代表是最高权力，而不是国王，也不是贵族。现在，这有一个权宜之计的原因，那就是
lords, you know, despite all this purging, the lords still refuse to pass the legislation to create this new court that is going to try the king. And so the commons respond with this declaration where they say, well, we're supreme anyway, so it doesn't matter. But it's also, I think, something that is coming out of all of these years of discussion, all these leveler ideas, the kind of radical ideas that are coming out of the army rank and file, that actually it's the people who are supreme. So on the 4th of January, they say the people are under God,
贵族们，你知道，尽管进行了所有这些清洗，贵族们仍然拒绝通过旨在建立这个审判国王的新法院的立法。因此，下议院用这份宣言作出了回应，他们说，好吧，反正我们是至高无上的，所以这没关系。但这同时也是，我认为，源于所有这些年的讨论、所有这些平等派思想、源于军队普通士兵的那些激进思想，即实际上是人民至高无上。所以在1月4日，他们说人民在上帝之下，
the original of all just power, the commons of England in parliament assembled, being chosen by and representing the people have the supreme power in this nation. And that's the kind of the key, isn't it? Yeah. That's the justification.
所有正义权力的源泉，英格兰下议院在议会中集会，由人民选出并代表人民，拥有这个国家最高权力。这就是关键所在，对吧？是的。这就是正义性所在。
And the army is casting itself as what the kind of the armed wing. Yeah. The British people. Yes. And, you know, in practical terms, the british people yes and you know in practical terms they they do have you know much greater claim to be representative than the house of commons does even or you know certainly the house of lords so yes and and on the um there's this prophetess from Abingdon, Elizabeth Poole, who is, I mean, she's kind of humble background, who nevertheless declares to be speaking the truths of God. And she's brought up, isn't she? And kind of very seriously consulted. And so she's, that's a kind of, I mean, what's going on there? Because that seems quite, is that expressive of an anxiety that maybe God's will does need to be skipped?
而军队把自己塑造成了什么样的武装僚属。是的。英国人民。是的，而且在实际层面上，英国人民，是的，而且在实际层面上，他们确实拥有比下议院甚至（或者当然）上议院更大的代表权主张，所以是的，而且在……有一个来自阿宾顿的女先知，伊丽莎白·普尔，她，我的意思是，她的背景很卑微，但她却宣称自己在说上帝的真理。她被带上来了，对吧？并且受到了非常认真的咨询。所以她，这是一种，我的意思是，那里发生了什么？因为这看起来相当，这是否表达了一种焦虑，即也许上帝的意愿确实需要被忽略？
Yes. Yeah, yeah, totally. They're willing to give this woman an audience because they are desperately keen to understand what God's providence, you know, what God's will is. It's a kind of theological focus group. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And she says, yeah, bring him to try, but don't kill him, basically. Basically.
是的。是的，完全是。他们愿意给这个女人一次接见的机会，因为他们迫切渴望了解上帝的护理，你知道，上帝的意愿是什么。这是一种神学焦点小组。是的。好吧。她说，是的，审判他，但基本上别杀他。基本上。
So at that point, right, ted that parliament's been purged the army leadership have been radicalized they've all decided on the trial at that point when they're talking about a trial is there even the slightest doubt in their mind that he will be found guilty i mean is it is it is it basically a show trial from the beginning or do they genuinely think well maybe he'd be acquitted? Who knows? Yeah. So obviously this has been a major kind of source of debate among historians. And my feeling is that there isn't really any. I don't think there's any doubt that Charles is going to be found guilty, personally.
所以在那个时候，对吧，特德，议会已经被清洗了，军队领导层已经激进化了，他们都决定了审判，在那个时候，当他们谈论审判时，在他们心中甚至有一丝一毫的怀疑他会被判有罪吗？我的意思是，这从一开始基本上就是一场作秀审判，还是他们真心认为，好吧，也许他会被无罪释放？谁知道呢？是的。所以这显然一直是历史学家之间的一个主要辩论来源。我的感觉是，真的没有。我个人认为，毫无疑问查理会被判有罪。
It's interesting to look at the trials that happened in February of 1649. So after Charles has tried, basically other Royalist commanders are put on trial before the same body, the High Court of Justice. And unlike Charles, all of those defendants actually recognise the court and enter pleas. They all plead that they're not guilty. They're all found guilty. Right. You know. Yeah. And what is their fate?
看看1649年2月发生的审判很有趣。所以，在查理受审之后，基本上其他保王派指挥官也在同一个机构——高等法院——面前受审。与查理不同的是，所有这些被告实际上都承认了法庭并进行了抗辩。他们都辩称自己无罪。他们都被判有罪。没错。你知道。是的。他们的命运是什么？
Well, so this is interesting. And this is where perhaps I think there is more wriggle room. Three of them are executed, but two of them are let off. And what happens basically is they're all condemned by the court, but their sort of punishment is then reverted to Parliament for ultimate decision-making. And Parliament basically votes that three of them are going to die and two of them, the votes turn in their favour, one of them by just one vote, by the Speaker's vote.
嗯，所以这很有趣。这也许是我认为有更多回旋余地的地方。他们中有三人被处决，但有两人被放过了。基本上发生的情况是，他们都被法庭判刑，但他们的某种惩罚随后被退回给议会进行最终决策。议会基本上投票决定其中三人将死，而另外两人，投票对他们有利，其中一人仅以一票之差胜出，也就是议长的那票。
Wow. Who's an old mate. Who's an old mate. Ted, the key thing that you said there was that Charles I does not recognise the court. Yes. And that essentially is the key, because if he does recognise the legitimacy of the court, then he is destroying the ideological basis for the kind of monarchy that he's always upheld i mean is that basically the issue for him yes yes and uh you know he's got very good grounds his position is a very strong one um uh in in terms
哇。那是个老搭档。那是个老搭档。特德，你刚才说的关键点是查理一世不承认这个法庭。是的。而这本质上就是关键所在，因为如果他承认这个法庭的合法性，那么他就是在摧毁他一直维护的那种君主制的意识形态基础。我的意思是，这基本上就是对他的问题吗？是的，是的，而且，你知道，他有很好的理由，他的立场非常坚定，
of the strategy that he uses i should also say it's a strategy that is anticipated as well. So there's a royalist newsletter writer, Marchmont Nedham, who predicts in his manuscript newsletters that what's going to happen is the king is not going to recognise the court, he won't plead, and he'll be found guilty pro confesso, as if he had confessed. But what will happen is that the king is not going to be executed. Instead, the kind of sword will be kind of hanging over his head. And this will be used as a way of getting the king to the negotiating table to agree to all the things that...
就他所使用的策略而言，我还应该说，这也是一个被预料到的策略。所以有一个保王派通讯作家马奇蒙特·内德姆，他在他的手稿通讯中预测将要发生的事情是国王不会承认法庭，他不会进行抗辩，他将被判有罪（pro confesso），就好像他已经认罪了一样。但将要发生的事情是国王不会被处决。相反，某种剑将悬在他的头上。这将成为迫使国王坐上谈判桌以同意所有那些……
But the king doesn't in the long run. But the king won't do that, yes. So he is a martyr to that degree. And as Charles said, at this point, so the winter of 1648, 1649, but the king won't do that yes yeah so he's he is a martyr to that degree and it's charles ted is at this point so the winter of 1648 1649 they're setting up the court um does he have i mean this might sound a stupid question does he have legal advice i mean is he meeting with people who are telling him his barrister discuss yeah discussing his strategy kind of thing yeah i mean i think that's an interesting question i think the short
但从长远来看，国王并没有这样做。但国王不会那样做，是的。所以从这个程度来说，他是一个殉道者。正如查理所说，在此时，也就是1648年至1649年的冬天，但国王不会那样做，是的，是的，所以从这个程度来说，他是一个殉道者，查理，特德，在此时，也就是1648年至1649年的冬天，他们正在建立法庭，他有——这听起来可能是一个愚蠢的问题——他有法律咨询吗？我的意思是，他是否在与那些告诉他他的大律师讨论、讨论他的策略之类的人会面？是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个有趣的问题。我认为简短的
answer i think not really because he's by this point he's a very close prisoner so you know they have finally learned the lessons of you know 1646 through to uh late 1648 well the king's been trying to escape multiple multiple times and had various people passing intelligence to him so by this point he's a very close prisoner and he's still guarded by thomas harrison isn't he yes so we we escaped multiple, multiple times and had various people passing intelligence to him. So by this point, he's a very close prisoner. And he's still guarded by Thomas Harrison, isn't he? Yes. So we don't have the same situation as we get with actually what happens in the trials in February 49, where in fact, we know that John Lilburn was helping to advise those royalist prisoners on their defence. And they're actually allowed defence counsel
回答是，我认为并没有真正意义上的，因为到了这个时候，他是一个被严密关押的囚犯，所以你知道，他们终于吸取了1646年至1648年末的教训，当时国王多次试图逃跑，并有各种各样的人向他传递情报，所以到了这个时候，他是一个被严密关押的囚犯。而且他仍然由托马斯·哈里森看守，对吧？是的。所以我们没有遇到像49年2月审判中实际发生的那样的情况，事实上，我们知道约翰·利尔伯恩当时在帮助建议那些保王派囚犯进行辩护。他们实际上被允许有辩护律师，
because they recognise the courts. They're actually allowed some very high-status lawyers. Matthew Hale works on behalf of those royalist prisoners. Doesn't do them any good at the end of the day, but they have a lot of good legal advice. So this is something that, yeah, I think we have to give a lot of good legal advice. So this is something that, yeah, I think, you know, we have to give a lot of credit to the king himself in terms of how he constructs his defence.
因为他们承认法庭。他们实际上被允许拥有一些非常高地位的律师。马修·黑尔代表那些保王派囚犯工作。虽然最终对他们没有什么帮助，但他们得到了很多好的法律建议。所以这是一件，是的，我认为我们必须给予国王本人在如何构建他的辩护方面很高的赞誉。
And it is an impressive defence. So the king has been brought over from Carisbroke to a castle on the Solent. And then he's brought up by Major Harrison to Windsor. Is that right? Yes. And he's under close guard. Is there, so I'm sure we'll talk about Louis XVI and the French Revolution towards the end of this.
而且这是一个令人印象深刻的辩护。所以国王被从卡is布鲁克带到了索伦特海峡的一座城堡。然后他被哈里森少校带到了温莎。是这样吗？是的。他在严密看管之下。是否有——所以确信我们会在本集结束时谈到路易十六和法国大革命。
But is there a kind of an attempt to remind him of how far he's fallen? Is there a kind of Republican tinge to his treatment? Is he still treated as God's anointed by the people who are guarding him he is treated with respect but there's a definite kind of trimming down of um the amount of kind of well the number of people who can attend him um the ceremonial is much reduced um so so there is a definite kind of diminution of of of all of the sort of trappings of royalty um uh by the time he's sort of getting to to to windsor and how do they decide where because there is talk isn't that they might hold the trial at windsor but in the end they decide to hold it in whitehall and so what's the thinking about where the location should be for the trial
但是否存在某种试图提醒他自己已经堕落到何种地步的尝试？对他的对待中是否有一种共和主义的色彩？看守他的人是否仍然把他视为上帝的膏立者？他受到了尊重，但对于他身边的人数、以及随从的人数，确实有一种明确的削减。仪式的规模大大缩减，所以，当他到达温莎时，所有那些王室的象征确实有了一个明确的减少。他们是如何决定地点的——因为有传言说他们可能会在温莎举行审判，但最终他们决定在白厅举行，所以对于审判地点的选择有什么样的考虑？
well i think you know the the thinking about so the trial takes place in westminster hall um in the past of westminster and if anybody's been into westminster hall it's a huge space it's this this magnificent medieval hall um william rufus yes yeah uh and um in terms of you know uh the choice of that as a venue, it's a couple of things. One, they want this to be a very public trial, and Harrison actually says to the King, you know, this, I'm sure this wasn't meant to be reassuring, but the King has a conversation with Harrison whilst they're, you know, en route towards Windsor, and Harrison assures him that they're not going to just sort
嗯，我认为你知道，关于——所以审判在威斯敏斯特大厅举行，在威斯敏斯特宫内，如果有人去过威斯敏斯特大厅，那是一个巨大的空间，这是一个宏伟的中世纪大厅，威廉·鲁夫斯，是的，是的，而且，就选择这个作为场地而言，有几点原因。第一，他们希望这是一场非常公开的审判，哈里森实际上对国王说，你知道，我确信这并不是为了让人安心，但国王在前往温莎的途中与哈里森进行了交谈，哈里森向他保证，他们不会只是谋杀他或把他踢下楼梯，而是会以一种让全世界都能见证的方式对他进行审判。这就是他们想要的。他们想要非常非常公开的东西。威斯敏斯特大厅可以容纳成千上万的观众。另一件事是，这也是过去曾举行过重大国家审判的地点。因此，火药阴谋的策划者就是在威斯敏斯特大厅被传讯的。这里也是关键法院国王座堂、大法官法院的所在地。所以他们试图通过这表达一些关于这里同样是正义之座的信息。抱歉，威斯敏斯特大厅里是否有必须被拆除的王室权威的象征？
of murder him or kick him down the stairs, but instead, that he will be proceeded against in a manner in which the world can witness. And so this is what they want. They want something that's very, very public. And Westminster Hall can accommodate thousands of spectators. The other thing is, it's also the site where great state trials have taken place before. So the gunpowder plotters are arraigned in Westminster Hall. It's also the site of key courts, King's Bench, Chancery take place there. So they're trying to say something about this as being kind of a seat of justice as well. Sorry, are there symbols of royal authority in Westminster Hall that have to be taken down?
是的，嗯，当他们为审判搭建场地时，这是关于这里还发生了什么的另一个重要事情，也许不仅仅是在审判一个坏国王，你在我这个经过裁剪的虚拟背景中是看不到的。但当他们建立法庭时，他们还竖立了一个新的纹章，这后来成为了英格兰联邦的纹章。所以它移除了王室纹章，取而代之的是联邦的纹章——圣乔治十字和爱尔兰竖琴。今天的节目就到这里，明天请继续收听我们的下一期节目，或者你也可以随时
Yeah, well, by the time, you know, when they set it up for the trial, and this is one of the other significant things about, you know, what else is going on here, and it's maybe not just a bad king who's being tried, is that you can't see it in the way that it's been cropped, my wonderful virtual background here. But when they set the court up, they also put up a new coat of arms, which is what becomes later the coat of arms of the English Commonwealth. So it's removing the royal coat of arms, and instead we've got these arms arms of the commonwealth of the of the cross of St George and the Irish heart. Now that is the end of today's episode but tune in tomorrow when we'll have the next instalment or alternatively you could always
在 restishistorypod.com 加入《历史的其余部分》俱乐部，你就能立刻收听。我们从不错过任何宣传的机会。不管怎样，暂时来说，我是主持人，他是主持人，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。有关额外单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restish 主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少许娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
join the Rest Is History club at restishistorypod.com and you'll get it straight away we never miss a promotional opportunity anyway for the time being it's goodbye from me and it's goodbye from him thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restish host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加入 Rest Is History 俱乐部，网址是 restishistorypod.com，你就能立刻获取内容，我们绝不会错过任何宣传的机会。不管怎样，暂时先这样，我是我，他是他，感谢收听本期的《The Rest Is History》。如需获取加长节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。欢迎收听《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八香八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加长节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。